suzanne benoit et pdg d'aéro montréal
bonsoir madame benoît bonsoir monsieur
fignon est ce qu on assiste en ce moment
selon vous selon votre analyse que vous
voyez à une deuxième vague de mises à
pied dans le secteur de l'aérospatiale
mais en fait je pense qu'on continue à
mettre à pied on est frappé de plein
fouet par la crise comme vous savez les
entreprises font le maximum pour retenir
les employés c'est c'est inévitable
n'ont pas le choix que de laisser partir
des compagnies et des employés et elles
doivent france décision là qui sont cas
dit il
mais on savait dès le départ on a déjà
eu malheureusement des coupures on eu
plus de 4000 postes qui ont été coupées
aujourd'hui d'autres annonces
alors ça continue et malheureusement je
pense qu'on va en avoir encore beaucoup
vous prévoyez au cours des prochaines
semaines prochains mois encore combien
de compression un ordre de grandeur
ben écoute et tant qu'on n'aura pas
trouvé de façon de faire voler les
avions de sécuriser les jambes un nous
on est un parti dans la chaîne des
services est un effet domino alors les
avions sont cloués au sol
les compagnies aériennes ne freine pas
possession des nouveaux avions qui sont
doivent être livrées par les avis en art
donc automatiquement toute la chaîne
d'approvisionnement est impactée c'est
difficile de vous dire combien les
subventions salariales étaient en
quelque sorte une sorte de palliatif je
dirais ça nous a permis de préserver des
emplois mais ça vire des nouvelles
conditions pour les subventions
salariales et plusieurs grandes
entreprises se qualifie tout juste lui
même y en a qui se qualifieront pas donc
j'anticipe des mises à pied encore au
pot des prochains mois il vous attend du
canif vous attendez quoi du gouvernement
fédéral dans les circonstances
maintenant les circonstances il faut que
le gouvernement fédéral
passez à l'action alors au gouvernement
du québec
on a eu une excellente écoute on a lancé
une initiative l'alliance pour la
relance dès le mois de juin on est
arrivé avec des propositions en matière
d'innovation de productivité des mesures
très concrètes chiffré mais
malheureusement on comprend que le
gouvernement fédéral a aussi d'autres
facteurs qui sont très touchés par la
crise le secteur aérospatial sur un
secteur de pointe et on a besoin d'une
stratégie dédiée pour le secteur
aérospatial
les autres réductions dans le monde ont
eu l'appui des gouvernements on regarde
la france l'allemagne les états unis le
royaume uni oui en fait les
gouvernements ont clairement annoncé
leurs couleurs et ont donné des sommes
incroyables pour soutenir leur industrie
et nous on n'a pas encore eu
malheureusement de recours de droit on
avait on a présenté un tableau temps
tombent je sais pas s'il traîne quelque
part dans les régimes un tableau sur le
soutien gouvernemental par rapport aux
revenus des billets d'avion d'un secteur
aérien précisément qui on voyait qu aux
états unis on est à 36 37 % en france
aussi autour de 35% et là on descend je
crois que l'allemagne est autour de 19%
merci on a trouvé le tableau la france
36 les états unis 32.7 le japon 22,1
l'allemagne 19.5 on descend et le canada
est à 1,3 pour cent des revenus de
billets d'avion en 2019 est-ce qu'il est
clair pour vous que le soutien
gouvernemental canadien n'est pas au
rendez vous c'est clair c'est très clair
vous avez les chiffres devant vous et
nous on fait tout pour expliquer au
gouvernement que on est intervenu c'est
l'effet domino c'est des bases
communicants spock les avions faut
ouvrir les frontières de façon
sécuritaire progressive il faut que les
avions retournement ciel pour que
l'industrie aérospatiale d'industries
manufacturières puisse fonctionner est
libre et ses pièces aux avionneurs tout
est au ralenti on fonctionne à 50% on en
a pour quatre ans imaginez les parcs
cela
assure la relève en aérospatiale on
essaie par tous les moyens dont on était
la flamme dernière avec le ministre
boulet pour convaincre les gens de
s'inscrire dans les écoles aller dans
les programmes d'ingénierie de
techniques aérospatiales ou dans
d'autres domaines connexes
c'est très difficile pour nous parce que
le massage est pas très positif mais on
est des milliards on va s'en sortir et
j'ai bon espoir que le gouvernement
fédéral va être au rendez vous
prochainement pourquoi quatre caves ou
de 4,0 à brand cameron parce que les le
temps qu'on le temps qu'on mette au
point un vaccin qu'on sécurise les gens
que les avions se remettent à vos yeux
c'est pas moi qui dis là c'est les
experts partout sur la planète
alors avant que l'on revienne aux
niveaux de 2010 9
on anticipe que ça soit pas avant 25
kame début 20 25
oui cette crise qui perdure
contrairement la crise financière de
ça s'est réglé en un an je dirais un
ennemi ils ont recommencé
mais là c'est quatre ans alors c'est
très profond d'où l'émergence de live
fédéral pour investir en innovation
d'autres termes tous nos talents nos
ingénieurs nos écosystèmes de savoir si
au québec au canada
c'est quand même plus de 200 mille
employés des ingénieurs de haut niveau
ces ingénieurs vont aller dans des
endroits dans le monde où les
gouvernements se sont prononcés alors
dit on investit mais pas ici au canada
alors le cri du coeur est très clair
madame benoît merci à la branche r 6 et
6 2